lescott après duellistes alien blade
runner les djeunes vous choisissez dans
votre dernier film un thème beaucoup
plus réaliste pourquoi la réponse ça
prend du temps
je crois que metteur en scène vous voyez
il cherche toujours de nouveaux sujets
moi je voulais bouleverser un peu mon
rythme quoi jouer je pas je me tourne
toujours vers le passé vers l'avenir
alors j'ai recherché des thèmes
contemporains je voulais une histoire
d'aujourd'hui et sur des personnages
d'aujourd'hui dans des situations
d'aujourd'hui
et cette histoire elle m'a plu parce
qu'elle ne faisait pas servi même peu
comment dire à des années 40 se répète
un film de john garfield avec grace
kelly ou deborah kerr a écrit c'est ma
contribution au film sur la vie
d'aujourd'hui quoi mais c'est encore un
peu dans le passé des deux mais l'esprit
de l'histoire est en fait très années 50
années 40 et à la faim en particulier la
fin et très moral vous avez fait des
tests je l'envisagé plusieurs dénouement
avant de faire un choix définitif saison
why why cantona fait le scénario en
avait trois femmes possible
les deux autres il y avait la femme
française qui aurait été que le cas il
restera qu'aucune des fang initial et
l'autre fait quand même dira le brave et
un peu la fatalité quoi il reste à
connaître femmes bien sûr aux le nerf de
l'histoire c'est le déchirement de cet
homme entre ces deux femmes voyez les
personnalités des deux personnages
c'était tout ce qui cause des f
le fait que l'anglais de l'argent koh
lanta n'a aucune importance à la
situation famille
demain de provins quentin de l'époque
comme passeur pour que l'homme il est
vraiment du mal à se décider
[Musique]
c'est d'être un problème quand même pour
un artiste de concevoir trois fins
possibles et puis de devoir choisir en
fonction chat pas moins du marketing des
tests
la position des managers compagnie le
choix qu on doit faire à la suite des
tests sur le marché commun aux états
unis est tout à fait justifié moi j'suis
d'accord parce que c'est comme je suis
pas moins six pendant la première dame
filmé devant un public de 900 personnes
à ces cinq personnes ils disent j'aime
pas où gm
ben il faut en tenir compte sinon on est
vraiment des coqs ouais parce qu'ensuite
légère ils oublient toujours que nous on
fait marcher industriels les gens il
parle du cinéma comme dinars moi je
crois que seulement dans certains cas
les filles me dure assez longtemps pour
qu'on les considère comme des oeuvres
d'art et la plupart du temps quand il
s'agit d'un travail de professionnels
j'étais petit mais marche bien et
d'autres veille marche pas et est vital
que nous on est des films qui se vendent
aquacole final c'est la fin de
l'industrie
vous êtes toujours beaucoup d'argent
pour vos films
même s'il s'agit cette fois d'un film un
peu plus réaliste le budget très élevé
j'ai remarqué que la première scène se
déroule à trois endroits différents
d'abord c'est une rue à new york ensuite
la façade elle était à los angeles et
quand on rentre dans le club et dans le
paquebot queen mary ces sacs en
plastique non mais le budget n'est pas
très élevé aux états unis on dépasse
maintenant moyenne pour un film 16
millions de dollars à nous à la favède
12 et demi alors mais vous n'avez jamais
envie que je suis pas moi parfois de
tourner des films je crois plus
personnelle en 16 mm avec deux personnes
dans une chambre en fait c'est
duellistes il n'y a pas coûté cher un
[ __ ] petit budget du ministre je pas
moi à l'époque il a dû coûter ce film ne
sait mieux dans la rue et nous on n'a
pas bougé et même à l'époque c'était pas
un chien mais j'ai l'intention de faire
des choses à partir d'une histoire
beaucoup plus complexe se voyait moins
une commandite commerciale et ses films
il devrait être tourné avec un petit
budget ça c'est sûr par exemple j'ai
envie de faire l âge amérique
comment votre film a été accueilli aux
états unis ok en fait pas trop mal je
veux dire que les gens qui l'ont aimé
les critiques ont été bonnes mais on a
eu tellement de problèmes que la
direction' des sociétés de production
que dans une certaine mesure la
publicité elle n'a pas été optimale est
vraiment il aurait pu avoir un meilleur
accueil vous entendez comment et que les
nageurs stephen donald les majors ça
fait 12 ans que je fais du cinéma que
valeur refuge strike et gratuite chéri
elles sont toutes différentes trois
directions différentes parfois se fasse
violer
c'est difficilement debout sont des
femmes et vos projets c'est quoi je
travaille à que paramount michael
douglas ou et qui sait le très bon
metteur en scène est allégé fille cheryl
ann sonné on tourne un film
il s'appelle black rain se passe à tokyo
voyez à tokyo japon et l'histoire crop
sa part d'un flic laisser mon tout le
monde s'y met polanski aussi si sûr à
l'effet qu'ils ont une vie fascinante et
c'est l'histoire d'un flic de new york
qui débarque à tokyo et que c'est de
retrouver mais comparé m voyait
[Musique]
peut-être
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou